so what do you do at Khan Academy I'm on
our adoption to you and recently I've
been working on learn storm which has
been very exciting and very busy as well
because we're coming up against may 9th
where we're doing the final in person
celebration so for people people outside
of the bay area are going to watch this
video what is learn storm sure so learn
storm has been this really fun layer on
top of the traditional Khan Academy
experience where as kids are working
through Khan Academy exercises they're
able to plug into a bigger communities
they're able to see themselves on
leaderboards they see their school on
leaderboards they see their city and
they're earning points towards moving up
in these leaderboards which has been
really exciting for kids because it
plugs them into a bigger community and
then underlying all of it has been this
amazing aspect of thinking about how do
we encourage the growth mindset and so
kids are not only recognized for
mastering skills on Khan Academy but
then also recognize really for the
hustle the grit the perseverance the
effort they're putting in and it's one
of the amazing things about the Khan
Academy system is that you really can
see when a kid is working working
working struggling to answer a question
and then all of a sudden they get it and
so it's been really neat because we've
been able to recognize both those
students that are the high flyers and
run through and mass or a bunch of
skills and then also recognizing those
kids that work really hard and so it's
been a tremendous effort and really
exciting it's it's taken off in the Bay
Area and really excited about what it
might mean so people know it's a pilot
this year we wanted to test it out I
think with some like seven or eight
percent of all students of the Bay Area
participating yeah we didn't know how
figure it would be but hopefully it's
something we extend absolutely yeah and
and what what is your day to day like in
this adoption team yeah it's wonderful
but it's a total whirlwind you never
know it's one of those things I think
with working on a pilot program where
one day you're out there talking to
superintendents and mayors and County
superintendents and the next day you're
the weeds looking at the data and making
sure that all the numbers are matching
up and making sure that you've got your
your eyes down your T's cross and then
the next day you're creating a set of
math activities for kids to do a giant
scavenger hunt in the final in-person
event so it's a varying role and fun
because you get to wear all these
different hats and you're going through
the experience and kind of developing
and designing as you go and learning as
you go and adjusting and so it's a every
every week is pretty different and what
I mean were you always doing this what
have you done in the past yeah so I'm
either at or before me yeah sure before
Khan Academy was working in consulting
and working primarily in k-12 education
so working with a whole variety of
organizations and it was a wonderful
experience you got to go in and meet a
lot of really interesting people in the
field and learn about what they were
doing and learn about their
organizations and it was everything from
school districts to nonprofit supporting
those school districts to philanthropies
and so you went in and got to learn
where they were and then help them get
to you and they place and that was
wonderful and then you know a lot of
coming over here was recognizing the
power of this particular organization
and getting really excited about it and
ready to dive deep in one place and what
would you say you know if you're if
someone is a younger person is watching
this video and okay I want to do what
she's doing what skills should they
develop what should they work on what's
it say study yeah it's a great question
and I think you know the key is to
pursue something that you're passionate
about I think that's the number one most
important thing and if you figure that
out and you go after it and put in that
hard work or you're going to develop a
set of skills along the way and
everyone's path to getting here is
different and I think you know for me I
took one path but that doesn't
necessarily fit for somebody else and I
think the the key is that go after your
passion and you'll figure out figure out
the rest Lydia look for if you if you
wanted to find someone else you know say
the team grew
what kind of what kind of traits would
you look for in someone to be part of
the team yeah I mean one of the key
things is that great teammate the person
who's willing to jump in and help out
and any which way that they can and they
see an obstacle and they don't just stop
they say okay well how do I break
through it and get get around it and you
know another is kind of the dream or the
person that's thinking about okay well
what could this be and how big could we
make this or where where could we go
deeper who could be who else could we
talk to you and and that person and who
really just continues to push and
continues to think about how do we take
our work to the next level and and again
it's somebody who cares tremendously
about the kids at the end of the day and
and that's front and center for for all
of us on our team is thinking about and
keeping those students at the front of
our minds is we're thinking about how
we're designing and creating different
initiatives different programs that were
building what's up I mean you know you
you're now here what would it what
surprised you about the experience at
Khan Academy yeah I think that one of
the things that I didn't necessarily
know when I came was just how
wonderfully diverse and interesting this
this team was that I was joining and one
of the things that I value tremendously
is how much I've learned from other
people that have been here and other
approaches to thinking about and solving
problems and we all come from very
different technical backgrounds and it's
one of the things that's amazing because
you bring that sort of a team together
and the potential is tremendous because
you have one person who's thinking from
one angle one person who's thinking from
you know design angle one person who's
thinking from the engineering angle and
and what you're able to create when you
bring in all these different
perspectives i think is something that's
much greater than just coming in with
with one particular area of expertise
and you know I knew that coming in at a
surface level I knew that there were
engineers and there were designers and
they were programmatic p
but where you see that intersection and
when that intersection happens which
happens all the time here it's
tremendous i mean i think the learn
storm is a perfect example of that and
what are you excited about right now i'm
excited about our potential to push
forward with these programs i mean i
think learn storm was us kind if I
wouldn't say dipping our toe because I
went a little bit bigger than dipping
our toe and submerging okay yeah yeah so
we're doing our left leg or right I was
something along those lines but I think
that what it really showed us and showed
me at least was the potential of what we
really can do if we put that cross
functional team behind an effort behind
a program and say let's run with this
and I think that the potential to reach
folks that haven't necessarily heard
about Khan Academy or heard about Khan
Academy three years ago and never
realized that Khan Academy has changed
and all of all of that that work all the
outreach that we can do with these types
of programs I think it gives us
tremendous potential to reach the
populations that we care a ton about and
the populations that we haven't yet been
able to reach and so I'm pretty excited
about about that and I feel like we're
at the tip of the iceberg and there's
just so much more that we can do and
that we can build awesome well thank you
for being part of this adventure
absolutely thank you